if you don't know you're very bullish on
the company what was the the best news
for Tesla you think out of today's press
conference about managing expectations
when the gen 3 product comes out I don't
think that customers with Model S have
range anxiety and this was clearly about
managing the inside the driver part of
the of the experience and with the
potentially smaller battery than Shen
three range anxiety will be a bigger
issue and I think this is going to
address a couple of those issues for
them and that's many years away yes
Theodore when do you expect the car win
did you expect the car wouldn't you
expect it now 2017 it'll be tied to the
gigafactory when the gigafactory is up
and running then we'll have the the gen
3 car Steve Levine what are the
technological limitations to getting
into creating this this car for the
masses right not the luxury
hundred-thousand-dollar Tesla or you
know whatever you want to spend in Tesla
they say the base price of 70,000 but
you don't have spending the average
price is a lot closer 100 yeah you know
to sell it a 30 thousand dollar car what
do they have to overcome technologically
that they haven't done already thanks
thanks i wanted i'll answer that but i
wanted to say something first and that
was a follow up to it to what mr.
O'Neill said I got a different message
from from what Elon said in his press
conference because he said that 200 mile
range is a passing grade for an electric
electric car he he criticized he scorned
what the question regarded GM's plans
for a 200 mile car he scorned that and
said if you have 200 miles that's only a
passing grade and that the sweet spot
that Tesla shoots for is 250 to 350
miles I saw that as a signal that that
the model 3 is actually going to shoot
for longer range that that it's going to
try to get into the 250 to 300 mile real
but the peculiar the model is the
cheaper version of the model that's the
one that starts at 70 and change has a
200 mile range or
according to Tesla the more expensive
version has a range that's closer to 80
I guess they say yeah and and and and
also he went on to say that it that even
if you do have 200 miles and you get
that passing grade it has to be a real
200 miles it can't be that you have the
electrician enough that you're crawling
along at 40 miles an hour that the
weather is perfect it has to be real
driving conditions so I I got the
impression that he was setting the bar
differently from how we until now have
been looking at that race among the car
makers for that for that car the 200
mile car in 2017 2018 I think he's he's
saying that at least there's going to be
the option to it to go further than that
it's interesting Theodore O'Neil you
know he's Elon Musk often sets a high
bar for example last quarter they said
there was sell over 11,000 cars they
sold 9800 when he sets a high bar so we
think of that as his own aspirations or
the promise from a public company CEO oh
I I think he knows exactly what he's
doing and if they can get the gen 3 to
get 250 to 300 miles I'm not sure where
they're going to shoehorn all those
batteries in but if they can do that
that'll be great that'll be super but
this the issue today that they talked
about in their press conference was
about software and not sit not really
about the batteries but how do how to
let the customer be comfortable with
letting the car control the charge a gas
back the planning aspect so that you
don't have to worry about running out of
battery power yeah and to be fair Steve
lavina was you know I one might mock
this I may have already marked it as
just a warning light coming in the
dashboard but in fact it does sort of
say hey you if you drive beyond the room
now about the drive beyond the range of
the nearest charging station so if you
don't turn around from their direction
you're going right now and get to a
charging station immediately it's your
own fault if you run out of juice right
he's saying what what musk said today in
effect is that range anxiety is a
psychosomatic malady it's totally mental
I'm going to be
i'm going to give you bedside manner i'm
going to be the cover i'm going to tell
you when you're sick when you're about
to be sick if you don't do something
about it my car he said my car's
effectively go far enough if i put and i
can put in a 500-mile battery he said
but but but but it would be dead weight
in the car so so so really what you need
is that kind doctor so Steve let me ask
you finally I mean do you think that the
competitive efforts to come up with a
better battery might actually alleviate
these worries of distance in a much
bigger way or is that still 20 too far
off pie-in-the-sky GM might have great
dreams but they're not going to get
there anytime soon now i think this
still is the essential tension in the
industry the the folks like GM and
really the rest of the industry that's
trying to create the superbattery and
thinks that that's where the tire hits
the road and then Elon Musk who thinks
I'm going to engineer my way there i'm
going to create the metal frame mental
framework for people to feel calm about
owning a and electric car and i'm going
to build a gigafactory a gigantic
lithium-ion battery type that cuts the
cost by thirty percent